hey what's up it's molly williams and
i'm chilling here with gq and we're
talking about my iconic characters
so many
white chicks
i don't know i think sean was high when
he called me up with this idea he don't
smoke weed but i think he was high on
green tea i think someone put weed in
his green tea because he called me up
he's like marlon we should play two
white girls it was like three in the
morning i said what we should play paris
and nikki hilton as detectives i said
bro
like you high he's like no i said well
then you need to smoke something to go
to sleep i hung up
next day
shows up to my house and it's passing
nikki hilton on the cover
of rolling stone he's like we should
play them
and then we watch something like it hot
and i was like yo we can do this
and then from there we just started
creating it and before you knew it
you know we showed it to my brother and
keaton was like well i like it
but you got to do 26 more drafts he went
all this long journey and he took it
from the city
and moved it to the hamptons and that's
when it all kind of started making sense
what's up money you got a problem what
you looking at my ass for
nah yo hold my poodle hold my poodle
that movie almost killed us seven hours
of makeup we'd work 14 hours after that
it takes an hour to take the makeup off
shawn and i will get two hours sleep for
like 65 days or 60 days we still manage
to hang out with our cast
and we still manage to write a series of
books
and write thugaboo which was an animated
series that was hard that one's killed
us makeup movies
until they learn how to like digitally
do it special effect-wise
that's a lot of work everybody's like
dude white chicks too i'm like [ __ ]
yourself
you do white chicks too i'm doing black
man movies how about we listen to a
little bit of music
[Music]
how did you know
i love this song
we wanted terry uh
we seen him in fridays friday two or
something like that and we was like
he'll be funny as this his role was
literally
a gem
from
the wayans joke toolbox we've been
watching that dude
since like the early 80s you know the
black dude
that loves
white women me and my brothers were
famous for a long time so we started
hanging out with those kind of brothers
and they'd be like man
it's snowing in here they have their own
code look at all these girl white girls
here man it's a blizzard they had their
own like language it was an inside joke
that we made it outside your hey white
chocolate don't stay in the sun so long
you may melt oh cotton tail i'm coming
[ __ ] like that that would be as hard as
it was man it was
it's funny
let's see i had a pepsi
girl
we gonna get along just fine
back at you
bask in the ambience
basking in the ambience no matter what
my character tried to do to get rid of
this brother
he would not
go away it was like him trying to the
whole date led up to that the belching
the farting
ordering like a wild person eating with
his mouth open picking his toes at the
table he's doing everything trying to
get this dude off his tail and then he
puts in this song that he thinks that
this black person this brother will hate
and he wants a loving the song oh this
is my favorite and it's like what do i
have to do
to get rid of this man and then he likes
me more that was just a lot of fun and
me and terry had a great great chemistry
on on on on screen and uh he used to
always tell me i got a crush on your
character he damn that cry when we
finished filming are you gonna put the
character face are you gonna put the
white makeup on again no [ __ ] i'm not
leave me alone
[ __ ]
are you telling me
that you
are not yeah i'm not a woman white
or the deception
the betrayal man you deceived me calm
down i'm an fbi agent i was uncovering
us negro please
didn't somebody tell you this was an
all-white party huh
someone get this [ __ ] away from me
anything
well i didn't have to get and that white
chick makeup was a great scene my
favorite scene well even in the white
chick makeup i would say the bathroom
with the feet
okay
as men we go to the bathroom like that
women probably do too but they're so
dainty and sweet and this and that to
actually see a sweet
little
white shake blew a bathroom up like that
it's like yo
but that scene and i think the scene
where we played bodega store on us
but once again what i loved was me and
sean improvising my brother keenan
didn't know what we was going to do
because we had nothing really written
and he was like do something anytime we
made my brother keenan proud it was a
a great moment for us because we knew we
just put another brick
in the building block towards success
scary movie
well shorty was based on a friend of
mine who was a wee head named shorty he
actually was mad at me after he
didn't see scary movie so he thought i
did him dirty like and he was like son
i'm suing you for character defecation
so you mean defamation no son defecation
cause you [ __ ] on me he's like i saw
brett william for a dream i was like i
didn't do you a record for a dream i did
do a scary movie and then he wound up
seeing a scary movie he goes [ __ ] my
bad that [ __ ] was hilarious uh i should
wait a grabby for that and make sure you
take your behind the class today i do be
going to class lunch is not a class
shorty it is when you got the munchies
i won wee head of the year i think two
times with shorty and then shorty was
funny because it was like when we wrote
the original scary movie we didn't have
nothing really written for shorty so
i'll get the set and keenan go okay
i'm not sure they're going to do today
so a lot of those scenes we kind of did
off the cuff like in the moment like yo
here's what's funny for sure here the
night before he'd be like what sure they
gonna do tomorrow i'm like give me a
second i go get my computer i'd be like
here's the sets here's what we're doing
we're in the house we're doing this i
just bet uh shorty's gonna freestyle
with the killer and here's how it's
gonna go
peace
yo
that was the illest drama i ever seen
what would you say was the difference
with shorty going into scare movie too
besides the hair his afro grew i think
same character
different situation you know he's always
going to be
the weed head perspective of
what would happen from a high person's
perspective like him sitting there
and he gets rolled up by a tree
into a blunt that was straight out of
poultry guys
i'm sorry i didn't mean to smoke your
relatives please
i didn't do it by myself whitney and
bobby help me
i mean that was a great time man it was
just a special movie a really funny
movie where we was just going for the
gusto going for them laughs trying to
make people hurt yes it was scatological
and somewhat sexual sexual but
man some of that [ __ ] was funny
requiem for a dream
i read the script for recruit i was mad
as a black guy brothers don't even talk
like that i was kind of insulted like
come on who still talks jive this is
1990 something can we how about they
update the language but this is a hubert
selby book and they wanted to be
authentic i wasn't really feeling it my
agent was like yo you gotta reread this
i'm gonna send you the book
i'm gonna write this book the same thing
and then he sent me the movie pie and
when i saw a pie i instantly was like
wow this director is amazing i want to
know what his vision is we had a meeting
when he told me about the language and
he wanted to keep it authentic and
create its own world and i was like okay
i'm i'm with it i saw the vision but he
was like yeah that's all that's nice but
you're not getting this role i'm not
getting nobody on the wb network is
going to be on this so i auditioned five
times i wore the same outfit i didn't
wash for three days
i made my own fake drug kit smoking
cigarettes which you know i don't do and
my boys was like why are you talking
like that
my friends are actors too they had no
idea i was just
doing my character when i got the world
the role there's like i really thought
you was going through something i almost
called to get you in rehab yeah
one time the fifth time
he saw was serious and um i got the role
nothing
just thinking about you
being able
to showcase my dramatic
chops is always a a great thing for me
because it's like oh i didn't know
michael jordan knows how to shoot three
three-pointers it's always something to
have like when just when they think they
know you you've got something else that
they go oh i didn't know you could do
that you know it was a movie that you
know wound up getting a lot of critical
acclaim and it's like oh marlon
connected i'm like i went to performance
high school for four years i'm like bro
i got pain my mama died like i got a
well of tears comedy is hard
drama
for comedians is just being your natural
vulnerable self minus the jokes
now we just deal with the emotions now
we deal with the truth now we deal with
the feelings now we deal with the
subtext but it was good to showcase it
in a great movie and uh darren did a
great job with that movie he cares about
everything in the frame as the director
she cares about the he walked me through
what the colors of fall
was gonna look like what the colors of
winter was gonna look like we walked
around the streets of new york in
february with no shirt on i said what
the hell are you doing why am i doing
this it's cold he said because you're
gonna be filming this
wintertime scene in june
when it's hot but i need you to remember
how cold it is and i was like [ __ ] i
grew up in new york i know how cold it
is with and without a jacket but he
cared you know i mean he cared about the
character he asked me what's three
things that i really love i said i love
joke i love
women and i love drinking he said you
can't do either
for the duration of the movie
why because i want you to know what it's
like
to fiend
for something i was like how about two
out of three let me keep the chicks man
i mean he cared and he had great
tools
and knew how to speak to every actor
every actor we had our own process and
he understood how to approach each one
of our languages you know and um i just
credit him he's a it was a great
experience
you know how heavy that camera was on my
little skinny back he put a whole camera
on on a rig on my list
you're running with this and he's like
all right faster i'm like fast i got a
70 pound camera on me and it was like
one of my last days filming and i just
take out the take out the take let's go
nobody understands how hard
physically doing movies acting in movies
can be everybody's like why do you work
out every day why do you go to the gym
so much why are you doing cardio i
prepare myself for the rigorous
amount
of physical activity i'm going to do
when i do movies it's a lot and it
looked great you know i it's all trust i
trusted him you know what i mean and
when i saw pie i was like i want that
shot
be careful what you wish for
don't be a menace to south central while
drinking your juice in the hood
bro let's start with we did 27 drafts
before we even filmed the movie my
brother was like if you don't want to
write movies then this is what you're
gonna have to do i think me and my
brother went to see boys in the hood
which was great movie and we saw
minister society another powerful movie
and then south central it went from
being
good to like common denominator to
always be like this kind of character
there's always a crackhead there's
always the super tough gangster and we
just started seeing all these common
denominators and it was just like nah
and then it started getting bad and
that's when it started getting good
and for us the
darker and more tragic the scene the
funnier the potential for us i figured
i'd get me a job at the post office you
know maybe at a bank you know i'm saying
good man work real hard work my way up
the manager we need more black people
like this you know what i'm saying learn
the system a little bit and i'll rob
that [ __ ] blind we just like to
dig
and where everybody else sees like this
dark gritty drama wheels like oh you
know what's funny about that me and my
brother sean got a couple of big pads
and filled those papers back and forth
for jokes and i got the first rough
draft of don't be a medicine as soon as
i finished
back to california and we started
putting a movie together and keenan
would kept taking the script putting a
detonate on it blowing it up and go
start from scratch 17 rewrites later
more
we was at 27. we me and sean we damn
never wanted to cry and then we
finally filmed the movie and keenan
directed this reshoot and then he edited
together
and that became the classic don't be a
menace is it was a hell of a journey you
know that chronic make me paranoid baby
come here your full dog mark ass trick
give me some love you have to stand this
was an era when like dr dre and snoop
and west coast music was banging into
everybody's systems lope dog was a
combination of old dog from minnesota's
society and snoop dogg and ice cube we
just want to make him the worst
[ __ ]
ever
and we put weed in his hair and a condom
and a pacifier and a car intended like
what was important to him at the time
pants sagging and we just
hey
just the way his whole ignorance was
because you know he was going gonna be
that marquez trick you know we just
wanted to make him the most west coast
gangster dude but with a soft side he
got all these text nines on them but hey
you guys were these bunny slippers there
was so much texture to the characters
that we was creating for the movie
that's a classic man it's great that
kids are still discovering that like yo
this is a classic we're trying to change
your mood we try to make people laugh
till they hurt that's all
in living color
working on living color was
nerve-racking
intimidating educational and
fun but i learned to work hard
you're on a show
where every last single cast member
is like gonna be a legend i was the baby
of the bunch and nobody me and sean and
nobody was writing sketches for keenan's
little untalented brothers
and i was keen and talking so we had to
write our own sketches and so shawn and
i would stay up all night long because
that's what the cast would do jim carrey
damon kim they would stay there until
like three in the morning writing their
characters so man sean we'd say to like
five in the morning six in the morning
cause we're just trying to get one or
two things in and that's why i learned
to write once me i joined the show me
and sean we started writing sketches the
first sketch we wrote was
just nothing wrong i'm about to go with
no man's ever gone before beat me up
scotty and then from there i wrote mr
ugly man which was the take on
shopping rings i said it three times you
still don't understand if you look up
the word ugly in the dictionary right
there on the page you see a picture of
me yeah we was just writing all these
funny sketches and they actually started
making it and it started giving us
confidence character that i think
surprised me and everybody else that was
probably became one of my favorites was
when i did the wanda sketch jamie had a
character
the ugly woman it was a table reed and
they needed the ugly man they picked me
to read it like i said they never write
sketches for me pardon me was like am i
that am i ugly am i like like what
you're trying to say so i did the ugly
man and that's why i did this guy i hear
luther and i just try to out ugly wanda
and it was funny because she was dogging
him the whole time the way everybody
always dogged her
and they
actually
found a connection because she hurt his
feelings and they fell in love it was
just a lot of fun improvising with jamie
because jamie was just throwing stuff
out the back pocket i know he was going
to do it and i just was just
going with the punches we don't need
them
hey hey hey you bruising
i'm bruising i'll be gentle i'll be
gentle
it was a lot of fun doing that sketch
and that's when i made my big brother
keenan laughs so hard whenever i made
keenan laugh or damien laugh i know i
was doing something special
wayne's brothers
all right so shawn and i
grew up watching television together
since we was and we shared a
twin bed every sunday morning we'd wake
up and watch abbott and costello a
little bit of lauren hardy three stooges
we love buddy teams we watched the
honeymooners and shawn and i used to
watch that show religiously and we said
one day we're gonna have our own sitcom
so that's when the dream began when we
left the lemon color when keenan left
and the family left ciao and i was like
what are we going to do
and we was like let's create our own
show what you doing
molly
hello out there
[Music]
my character of course was a lot dumber
on wayne's brothers than i am in real
life like i'm kind of educated i did a
year of college and sean's not
as hand-happy
as he was he used to slap the hell out
of me i'm like yo bro we're really not
the three stooges there's only two here
and that means i'm not hitting you back
so there's really one stooge but
the the love
the chemistry those two brothers had
each other's back and i think in real
life me and my brother
always had each other's back
[Applause]
i mean there were so many funny moments
on wayne's brothers we would just
improvise my whole goal was to make sean
laugh
[Applause]
they never really wrote shawn right so
we always all the my friends that was
writers we would all gather and rewrite
the complete the scene to give sean some
punchlines and point of view and
perspective and because they never knew
what i was going to do and i never knew
what i was going to do all week long i'm
just doing it doing it doing it
rehearsing when it came time for action
and we had that audience in front of us
i zoned out and we did it on our own
keenan damon's two untalented brothers
that's what they used to call us did it
on our own and we went five seasons
above the rim
yo kyle check out my sports illustrated
pose after me and you win the
championship sweetie
get off of me
it's funny the character boogaloo it was
written but it wasn't so there's a lot
of improv and a lot of like changing of
the character on the fly he had a
comedic element to him especially
because i was playing him but they
wanted to keep him at the end to be the
guy that killed birdie you know it was a
lot of a lot of improv on above the rim
so it was a lot of fun and you never
know how iconic things are
until the years later people are like yo
rim yo lebron's
tossed with the powder he got that from
above the rim all the characters a lot
of the actors in above i did know before
we actually started filming dwayne
martin and i were friends tupac shakur
and i were friends for
like years after juice because my best
friend omar epps worked with pock and my
boy benjamin marshawn worked with
popcorn juice so i would come up to the
juice set and i was listening to pop's
album before it came out then we started
hanging around and kicking in the
streets of new york and because we was
all performing arts high schools but we
all from ghettos so we had a lot in
common we had a lot of fun together too
and then bernie mac my brother sean and
i gave bernie mac his start in movies
damon put him in more money sean and i
put him on our show wayne's brothers and
then we casted him and don't be a menace
always kind of like the young prince of
the of the dynasty you know i always got
love love out in the in the hollywood
streets and uh i approached long-term
friendships rest in peace to all those
that still ain't here there's good times
tell him you've been working on my game
telling you we're gonna play college
ball together like college [ __ ] you
can't barely [ __ ] read how the hell
you going to college is this a [ __ ]
joke somebody tell me this is a [ __ ]
joke tell me somebody is it a joke
there was a lot of boogaloos that exist
in in the projects in the streets and
the jails it's always that guy the head
cheese always makes fun of always puts
down
everybody got a breaking point
people felt sorry for him and they
actually felt
vindicated that he actually did that and
no i didn't kill him in real life you
[ __ ] stop asking me that you idiot no
he was my friend boogaloo
boogaloo
killed birdie marlon
loved poc
respect
respect was
a great project i reached out to the
director i like to sit and have meetings
with directors i'm not going to do a
reading but i would sit down and i want
to know what your vision is and i want
you to hear my vision on a character
because there's nothing worse than going
into a project where you want to do this
character and they want to do that it's
like you got to be on the same page i
like to go to the sets let's see what
the sets look like what kind of wardrobe
and who's the dp and now start to ask
different questions about the movie
itself what kind of movie am i in so i
flew myself to atlanta got off the plane
i met with liesel i walked through the
production office and i immediately knew
that this woman had a vision knowing the
cast of jennifer hudson and for us with
the two oscar winners i was like yeah i
want to be here i'm in you may want to
loosen your grip on aretha
you know every minister's daughter i've
ever [ __ ] you don't want to
it's hard when you play someone real
right because you have to find a way to
marry your emotions and
your truths and your reality to their
reality it's kind of easier to play into
like an original character and i didn't
have a lot of footage it's another thing
you have a lot of footage and you can
sit and you can watch and you can mimic
ted white ain't aretha he has like a
minute and a half of footage out there
so that's what i had to watch and i just
noticed how he uh how he spoke and i
removed his hands and uh
uh he tried to find words to be uh
articulate
because back in the 60s that's what they
was trying to do the men of that era
they would
study to find the word because they
wanted to sound
uh intelligent so him i just
watched the isms i don't like to do too
much because i got to bring me
to the emotions i have to marry the two
and uh there's a balance so it's just
finding out how much of it to do and not
do when to lay off the punch when to put
it on
how to maintain
the consistency of the voice and the
isms even though
he's angry or he's hurt because you're
marrying your emotions and your truths
with their truths and their mannerisms
so you just have to be consistent we
could skip all the flowers and the
promises and the love [ __ ]
just have some fun
i like fun
and we'll have plenty of it i think
ted's motivating force was to love and
protect his woman and then he realized
that he wasn't man enough for the job
because it
would require him
to put his ego aside and his damage from
being hurt little boy aside to protect
something that was
greater than him but his intention i
think was pure i think he wanted to love
and protect his woman
but he got in the way he was his own
obstacle
you're not about to mess this up for me
where the hell do you think you're going
too long for this
from day one i as marlon chose to take
care of jennifer and we just built this
camaraderie of like
trust we could go anywhere in scenes
because there was a trust and it was a
love there and a friendship i think the
hardest scenes for us was when we had to
fight because we just
enjoyed each other so much that it was
like really
hard to have that much tension between
us well i'm crazy because i ain't going
nowhere i've been doing this 30 years
but i'm these are my best years i've
just been learning for 30 years i've
been learning how to write learning how
to produce learning how to modulate my
my acting approach i feel like keanu in
the matrix one day it hits you and you
go yo i'm nice with this i know what i'm
doing everything moves in slow motion
i'm at that point right now